welcome my name is Samuel Nixon Jr
and Alum of the MIT Gospel Choir
did you know that black students at MIT
have traditionally
relied on faith and music
for Spiritual sustenance through the
academic and social pressures of Life at
the Institute
yeah
the MIT Gospel Choir is a half century
year old example
of this tradition and meaningful
reliance
and from his early information in 1971
by others this body of faithful students
has grown from the informal original
group of 10 undergraduates Who quote
unquote simply
enjoyed singing to each other
according to the then president and
co-director Ricardo Hall to a more
formal and amazing group of solstice in
all walks of life
choir members have been singing
traditional gospel hymns and spirituals
for around five decades in local
churches in the Christian Fellowship
services at the MIT Chapel and all
around the Boston Cambridge area and
Beyond
today
during this holy season a segment of the
MIT Gospel Choir alums from across the
years a privilege to present to you
just a few moments of joy and
celebration of some of the historic
journey of this Legacy choir
won't you pause with us now to remember
some of the singing fellowship and
exciting moments of sharing the gospel
and psalm in this special MIT Gospel
Choir holiday
presentation
it's our joy to share with you with each
musical note in court
amidst the hustle and bustle of the
Season yeah we know we know
come relax and spend a few moments with
us
as you hear the sweetness of some
Melodies of memorable moments and Voices
of Faith of expressed during our student
years yes
even around the corners of the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
welcome
[Music]
back
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
now
ready
[Music]
nobody
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to MIT Gospel Choir
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
true
[Music]
foreign
hi my name is May white Wesson I was a
member of the MIT class of 1975 and I
graduated with a degree in course seven
I was a member of the MIT Gospel Choir
from its Inception until my graduation I
joined Maguire because I love to sing I
had always been a member of whatever
choir was age-appropriate for me from my
childhood until my graduation I enjoyed
being in the choir sharing time with
other black students at MIT because at
that time there were not many of us my
class had 45 or 47 black students and a
class of about a thousand so it was
quite a culture shock I had not gone to
an integrated school before my
appearance in Cambridge
so participating in McGuire gave me a
sense of continuity it gave me a system
of support
it gave me
time spent and something that I was
familiar with
I think the importance of the choir was
that it showed that MIT was changing a
bit there was some attempt at diversity
at least as far as admitting black
students to the ranks
uh I think we made a big impression on
the campus and also in the Greater
Boston the Cambridge Community we had
concerts we had programs
we sang in The Great Hall it was a
joyous time and experience
hello this is Michael Dixon
I was at MIT from 1984 to 1988 and I was
a base in the Gospel Choir sometimes a
tenor and they forced me to
um I just wanted to explain why the
Gospel Choir was so near and dear to my
heart during that time at MIT
it was awesome one of the best support
activities that I was able to be a part
of and a privilege I had a privilege to
participate in
um there are a lot of great friends a
lot of great challenges that we Face
together and those things have impacted
me to this day
as far as memories go I want to just to
just remember the times that we were
saying in Kresge with the New Jersey
Mass Choir
um it was an awesome poster that along
with that that
um concert that was the one that was
very colorful
um it was just a blessing to be a part
of that piece
um I remember the times where we
um able to connect with people like
Phillips Bryant who was
Hussein going up beyonder it's one of
those songs that you always used to love
to sing
um she was our Franklin she was a
powerful voice
um I also remember
um singing some original song from Daryl
Gaskin Daryl the roof is on fire gasket
I remember seeing in Psalms 150 I'm
saved by grace one of my favorites was 2
000 years ago awesome we sang some more
original songs from Tyrone Williams I
remember having Easter Service
um at Kresge with St Paul's AME
um and I remember you know being able to
go into the Oregon here at play at
Kresge
um I remember doing a tour but we went
to the
um toward the east coast
um it was a blessing but you know one of
the years we were the tour was during
the Challenger explosion where we lost
Ron McNair and a few other astronauts um
Ron McNair was in my team physics major
and in grad school and he was known by
many of the people we were actually
going to visit so it was a really solemn
time
we also sang Let Mount Zion Rejoice
um and we dedicated that song during the
tour but also be sang it um the
dedication building Ron McNair building
as well
um I remember connecting with people
such as my wife Crystal Dixon it was a
pleasure to work with and to be able to
interact with and so many other people
it was just an awesome thing but some
people stick out like for example China
Altman
um who was a just a courageous woman who
was part of the
media at MIT and she used to want to
helped us get those posters done amongst
other things but um she was just a
blessing and just to see how she was a
benefit to us and we've I think impacted
her as well
foreign
People Get Ready
the train is coming
don't need no tickets
all you need is faith
no baggy
the Lord
foreign
[Music]
just get on board
foreign
[Music]
there's no hiding place
people get ready for your time for sure
better get ready for the train is gone
[Music]
there'll be no time to get your house in
order
to live every day
just thank the Lord
so people get ready for the trains are
coming
don't need no ticket
you just
hang the Lord
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Malaysia oh
you're so straight to me
[Music]
[Applause]
please
[Laughter]
eyes
[Music]
[Applause]
wonderful savior
changes
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
let's have a warm welcome for the MIT
Gospel Choir
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
tell me that's nice
yeah yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
happy birthday
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you now I know you can't come here
too come on and go with me to my
father's house after my father's house
[Music]
oh my God please
[Applause]
[Music]
come on and go with me again
[Applause]
[Music]
well
I'm gonna go with me
[Music]
I was contacted sometime during the
summer of my preceding my freshman year
by a student at MIT Georgette Redmond
who was also from Ohio Toledo Ohio and
she called to contact me and and we
shared some information
um
about our interests mutual interest in
singing I was elated to find out that
there was uh such an organization
um but it turned out to be extremely
important to me later that same summer I
tragically lost my younger brother
um and uh the choir was a huge part of
the support uh that I received uh while
uh grieving but also needing to maintain
my studies and maintain uh most
importantly my faith I think we impacted
MIT and the community by uh
demonstrating our faith adding a a
different perspective to the faith
community
um at MIT from an African-American
perspective a a uh and
artistic perspective as well how did I
come to participate in the MIT Gospel
Choir
well I had a couple friends approach me
and
one at a time they were like sure we'd
like to join a gospel choir I said
I'm Catholic we don't really do gospel
choirs
um I'm not sure I'm already in the tech
Catholic Community didn't know who'd be
a a conflict of interest and thirdly I
really can't sing
and one by one they each said that those
were not issues and we're not conflicts
and I said I gave it a try and I'm glad
they persisted because I really enjoy it
it was great to see so many people from
different walks of life from the north
the south from the urban settings the
rural settings uh different
denominations get together and just
praise the Lord together
the experience was great especially in a
very high
stress
environment it was always time well
spent when I went to the practices with
the MIT Gospel Choir one day I invited
my parents and my brother down to
see us perform it was the first time we
had a full band we had a couple
guitarists and organists
um and I didn't tell them that I was
going to be conducting a couple songs at
the choir
turned out really well totally surprised
them I think uh my brother even asked if
I had switched religions which I didn't
but um it was you know very memorable
and I'm glad they came
[Music]
well
and Ransom captivates
[Music]
[Applause]
rejoice
[Music]
[Applause]
shall come to the holy
hell
Oh Praise
[Music]
I'm already
[Applause]
[Music]
hi I'm Cheryl Gill I joined the MIT
Gospel Choir in the fall of 1988 which
was my freshman year I was happy to join
the choir because it was a continuation
of my experiences in church and
community choir since my youth
I really appreciated the fellowship time
with the gospel choir
we encouraged each other as we practice
songs in rehearsal and I count several
lifelong friendships among the choir
members
our choir engagements were also an
Outreach Ministry I recall singing at
College Sundays at the Massachusetts
Avenue Baptist Church in Cambridge
and other area colleges but I think my
favorite memory was the spring 1989
concert with Candace Buckner singing God
is to a large audience in Kresge
Auditorium
our concerts gave us an opportunity to
reach people who didn't come from a
faith tradition
foreign
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you for taking the time to share
in this inaugural special presentation
by the MIT Gospel Choir alums during the
holiday season of 2022. we hope that you
found it enriching encouraging and even
exciting as we've revealed just a
glimpse of the history of over a half a
century that this organization has been
offering songs of Hope and help and
healing to a hurting world
the MIT Gospel Choir is a witness of
what has been a significant part of our
life-changing experiences while engaged
in our academic studies at MIT
as you've just heard and experienced and
the music testimonials and songs of just
a few of the alums in our group
you can tell that this organization has
been a blessing to many not just those
in the MIT Community but also across the
Greater Boston Cambridge area and even
the eastern coast of the United States
we are grateful to have made a
difference in the lives of the people
whom we've touched through song and
witness and our service to our community
and we'd like to give thanks to those
who have taken the time such as yourself
to hear our voices speak to the value of
the relationships and the fellowship
that we've experienced in our faith
Journeys
many have passed our way and still have
very fond memories of the bonds and
lifelong relationships that were
fostered through the MIT Gospel Choir as
it grew and developed over the years
there is much more to come as we look
forward to presenting more of the joyful
and revealing ways that the MIT Gospel
Choir has impacted the communities of
MIT Boston and Cambridge and the East
Coast
stay tuned for our 2023 series of
presentations that will be offered
through the activities of the black
alumni of MIT also known as bambit and
the MIT Alumni Association
it's an exciting time for a reunion for
our choir and we invite you to be a
special part of it
if you would like more information you
can contact May white Wesson at
maywesson AOL.com that's spelled
m-a-e-w-e-s-s-o-n aol.com or you can
also contact Samuel Nixon Jr at s Nixon
J2
aol.com that's spelled
s-n-i-x-o-n-j the number two at AOL.com
we will also be releasing announcements
through the bammit and MIT alumni
networks over the course of 2023. on
behalf of the MIT Gospel Choir alums we
hope you have a great rest of your 2022
holiday experience as you reflect with
us on the songs and the testimonies
you've heard
we look forward to you joining us again
in 2023 blessings to you and your family
in this holy season
this has been a production of the MIT
Gospel Choir alums
thank you
foreign
[Music]
stay at the Diesels coming